wrangle some kind of complications from  this position  i mean with two three minutes left on  the clock it's going to be  extremely difficult  extremely difficult to convert  what just happened mine is just bursting  into laughter  is it something in his head  what is this  we'll have to ask him afterwards  like this he'll have to reveal to us why  he's being so emotional right now why  he's laughing so much such a mystery guy  maybe he's just in a good mood playing  some good chess just after all  remember we have happy we have seen some  big blunders and stuff by magnus or some  bad play after you know hip-hop yeah  yeah that's true  when we hit like when these uh  situations occur when he starts laughing  or just  loses concentration maybe  and yeah artemis hasn't lost  concentration but maybe concentrating  too hard because he spent such a long  time on this last move